welcome
rejects to the dark
this is what happens when I have no idea
what the movie is about but I know the
title is underworld good so that was me
under the world yeah yeah I got it
run joxie baby that's right we're back
easy and if you love that then like this
video and come with us to the depths of
the underworld uh this is Kate
Beckinsale that's literally all I came
back at sale and lots of leather from
what I understand yeah I
leather
I want to see you be leather you don't
you don't then that means I just was out
in the sun for too long and wasn't using
the sunblock and it's a whole different
thing do you guys want to what's a
full-length Reaction watch along where
you sync up with your own copy well you
can do that over on patreon that's for
the super sexy rejects they're probably
wearing leather they are always wearing
leather that's what all the sexy people
do Greg and John cover several shows
over there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
again only in Leather so that's what you
want to see over there leather Daddy's
react
I love it leather daddy are you ready
for this I'm so ready I've been waiting
20 years what 20 years I think so I
think this came out in 2003. wow I've
only known about this movie for the last
like three years so I've been waiting
three years yeah well let's do it 2003.
we're about to enter the depths of you
okay let's go
[Music]
you know you cut a finger on that font
now I see silver I think of Beyonce's
tour okay
Beyonce own silver
oh vampires don't do well with silver
it's true the war had all but Grand to a
halt in the blink of an eye
pollution the most feared and ruthless
leader ever to rule the Lichen plan had
finally been killed it's very Hunchback
sure the Lichen horde scattered to the
wind in a single evening of flame and
retribution oh the like and horde there
are werewolves
oh is that what that is yeah Victory it
seemed was in our grasp the very
Birthright of the vampires I saw a
little buddha
oh a little bottom the leather cheeks
if he had proved unwilling to follow
Lucian to the Grave though lichens were
fewer in number drippy moist
we are here
we are well represented but the moon no
longer held her sway older more powerful
lichens were now able to change at will
oh is this black and white has it
evolved but our orders remained the same
it's very dissaturated
because it's badass world and there
aren't much color in badass worlds
if you don't have an angular face you
cannot be in the franchise nope what
your cheekbones look like they got Tim
Burton's casting guy like the weapons of
the previous Century we too would become
obsolete pity because I lived for it I'm
gonna be honest with you I think this is
latex not leather what I've been lied to
oh
it's that guy from Gray's Anatomy he's
Meredith's new bay oh baby is he a mixed
sweetie or a
mixed and then they were apart but maybe
now together I'm on season like 45 of
that show
I got ketchup
wow he has not aged in 20 years he is
make hunk vampire
that's Meredith's boo
he's doing a lot of good work for
Alzheimer's has he in the show
[Laughter]
oh my God that guy
Kevin
who is that guy
Bloods like the Bloods I don't even want
to say this is just east L.A right now
huh is Kate Beckinsale the prettiest
person to walk the Earth ever
could be because it does feel that way
right now whoa
oh
[Music]
that was cool yeah whoa so this is blade
it's like blade it's like the Matrix is
this also based on a comic
yeah you've never read underworld
I don't know man the comments might be
going wild
probably with bar product placement too
oh oh
no save the lady
I think it's too late
yes snap some pigs sometimes the way
editing is done in these movies makes me
very nauseous does that happen to you
ever in the chase scenes oh
[Music]
oh
it's cooler and Kate did it she jumped
through the windows cooler sorry guys
oh silver bullets
[Music]
nice these effects are pretty good yeah
not bad
whoa
It's a demo Gordon
all right werewolf gang let's go it's an
interesting transformation
do you want to understand what she is
yet
I don't think we're supposed to
he seems like a rogue you should touch
the silver though
nice Focus rack nice rack focused
oh that was goofy looking but I liked it
what are you talking about that was so
cool oh wait but she does have her teeth
and her eyes Okay so I guess in this
universe silver must not be as heavy for
Vamps or she could be like a day Walker
of some kind she's blade
whoa what are they this is very sin
city-esque
not bad would you rather be a vampire or
werewolf oh man
I guess
probably a vampire if I had to live as
one maybe a vampire I like werewolf
stories a lot though
yeah pan up into a Blood Rave
[Music]
what year was live 99
. okay so this is after
oh my God is this like a it's like an
underground werewolf fight yeah
like dog fighting between two werewolves
is it
oh
[Music]
is it freaking what's his name is that
Michael Sheen yes this is exactly his
name yeah yeah
you're running like a pack of rabid dogs
he looks like a pirate
but if you expect to defeat the vampires
on their own ground oh and if you expect
to survive
yes Taylor put some clothes on him no I
disagree nah pan down a little bit yeah
that is a perfectly framed Mound God I
gotta say I do love beautiful people I
know he looks way better than he does in
those like images I've seen from
Twilight
I saw it I don't think I've seen all the
Twilights either I never saw any
I've seen Snippets okay so now she's in
with the vamps
foreign
I mean they do look like they throw good
parties I would attend even if my blood
got sucked it's definitely any radiated
fluid of some sort ultraviolet
ammunition whoa rigel is dead and
Nathaniel could still be out there we
should gather the death dealers and head
back down there and force yes
my gut tells me and I am telling you
there could be dozens of lichens down
there who knows maybe more hundreds
we've wanted them to the brink of
Extinction
now is the time to get complacent very
well have your man Titan things up I'll
have sore and assembled search team no I
want to lead the team myself absolutely
not why it's her gut man we don't know
Soren we don't care about slime [__]
about Soren I hate him already I'd never
dream of treating you like that of
course you would I run along and make
sure she's dressed and ready for the
Rivalry for guests Julia Style's
knockoff yeah if you were the real
Julius Styles you would make better
choices in the script and you would
dance
well I seriously doubt Victor would want
you freezing to death in here staring at
his tomb for hours for hours no he'd
want the death dealers out there right
now scaring every inch of the city I'll
never understand why Victor left him in
charge
because he's a hunter he's a bureaucrat
not a warrior okay I'd take it back come
on we need to get you ready the party
Amelia's Envoy will be here any minute
who's a millionaire you know Amelia
Bedelia come on didn't you do your
research yeah
yeah yes dress
Who costume designer had some fun with
this one yes Queen of the day definitely
wear this one is perfect
that's actually the semi-realistic
enhance on the computer screen it's not
like all crazy clear
[Music]
coming still pretty convincing but
he's attractive yes he is for a human
who's attractive
show me I'll be the judge of that if you
ask me you take this Warrior business
far too seriously you can't undo the
Past movie has some bizarre audio issues
I know do you see this human quite often
I can't be positive but I'm beginning to
think the life ends of blast blast
Craven I'm serious I think they were
following him other than food why would
like in stock a human I like this guy is
liken the name for werewolves yeah I
didn't know that lycanthrope oh I heard
that before or lycanthropy
Great Scott oh yeah
it was so ageist
any progress let's find out
negative
oh no Corvin
it was a James T Corbin then here it
says M Corbin this is his brother he's
got a what the what where's Miller
what up dude break out that prison baby
you heading home yeah Nicholas gave me a
couple hours off you said you did a
terrific job tonight with the surgery
fun transition
to death dealers voice I know and the
candidate we lost them I feel like this
guy got so much work around this time
it's impossible
wowie the vampires they didn't realize
you were following a human no
uh you don't know that bro when Amelia
arrives to awaken Marcus in just two
days time we shall once again be United
as a single coven
there's a lot going on in this movie so
far yeah man it's a whole underworld
Society so does Kate want to protect the
humans
I don't know like why does she cares so
much about this guy she wants to know
why they're following him yeah what's he
got what what business does he have
being embroiled in the vampire werewolf
conflict
3B must be a big old apartment complex
that's how they do it in some places the
apartment used to be a prison
he does his job and then he goes hold
that thought
you know where we can find them
and try them at home or you'll have to
wait till they catch back uh oh he's not
in some kind of trouble is he
so young here
I know he's not in trouble at all I'm
just gonna act real suspicious and lick
my fangs
order make people's hair when skin wet
to use olive oil on set
a lot of the time yeah
answer the call leave The Matrix
sweet why are they after you
[Music]
like an automatic pistol what's your
guess as to why they're after him yeah
there's got to be something to do with
his brother maybe his brother was like a
big old lycanthrope muckety muck working
his way up the corporate lycanthrope
ladder you don't think anything to do
with his blood it could be could be
because they're running these tests
right
smart God they're like aliens yeah these
are the most interesting looking
werewolves
[Laughter]
let's go
you got infinite ammo unlocked
sweet would that work
I'm sure in some building it would
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
no look at those eyes
so now that he's been bit he's gonna
turn what happens
oh he's gonna spit the guy yeah the
blood into the tube right he wanted his
blood it really did make him look
monstrous
[Music]
I would love to be on set for this
moment are we what are they telling him
to do yeah what is the direction
what's going on
I like these weird industrial music
sound flourishes too
bad he is fast not a bad effect
[Music]
I already go in the middle
I feel like he would know enough to know
that you would just stab one of the
seats
yeah looking at that camera roll over
him
oh no
let's go what do you got
[Music]
okay
land on those feet must be very good at
the trampoline
God they made him look so freaking cool
I heard you
've lost a lot of blood if you don't
stop the car you're gonna get us both
killed I'm a doctor shut up and hold on
I'll be fine
[Applause]
dude
you've got to be smarter than that nice
[Music]
depends on how they Define the rules I
guess you don't like a wet dog
it's my favorite smell
I'll get you a candle of that for your
birthday
you know how to give a gift I don't know
oh yeah
[Music]
no I'm a lover loves shipper ships I
want them to hook up so bad dude mouth
to mouth mouth to mouth mouth to mouth
it's not how it happens anymore but this
is 2003. oh he never even got down give
her some of your blood
doctor
I am curious what happened to him
between 2003 and Gray's Anatomy I never
saw him if Michael is indeed the carrier
I've tasted his flesh just two days till
full moon soon he will be alike and he
will come looking for us dang I've
tasted his flesh about to upset the
established order it would be hard if it
wasn't so creepy it's hot because it's
creepy oh I didn't get that
positive
[Music]
I want that purple stuff purple drink
purple drink that is what Lil Wayne was
talking about
special werewolf vampire juice
definitely creature of the night little
Wayne
wait what's wrong with him oh he's
wolfing
what are we watching do you have any
idea why those men were off do you where
am I damn it man answer the question I'm
Celine I'm Selena Kyle the whole house
has been absolutely Buzz
oh God you're going to try to turn him
aren't you
of course not so why did you bring him
here because he's hot you saved my life
never even told me he wants to see you
this is completely unacceptable I just
need you to understand that Michael is
somehow important to the like oh so now
it's Michael would you just hear me it's
just beyond me why you're still obsessed
over this ridiculous Theory jelly
you're infatuated with in my gym now
that's a ridiculous Theory you're so
insecure man he is it's a super
unattractive
a bite oh my God you bite him too and
then we can answer the age-old question
about what happens if a vampire bites a
werewolf
that's how most women respond to me
what is he gonna do
oh yeah he's gonna do a cool guy jump
s
what is that that we keep saying must be
like Hive memories
evening leather top
you brought a werewolf into my house and
now he's an out there wolf
check this out
oh
go ahead squeeze off
murder William Shakespeare
you've copied the Lycan rounds silver
nitrate lethal dose straight into the
bloodstream ain't nothing to dig in
like do you hate the wolves in this I
feel bad for them craving been telling
more stories again eh well that's my
point it's nothing but a
name I've never underestimated Craven's
luster advancement the Victor believed
him and that's all that matters now
where are you going with this anyway
blindly accept this there's got to be
more to Victor picking him and what
actually happened there there's got to
be some kind of conspiracy you were told
you were told to set up shop and lay low
a human doesn't concern you besides I've
laid low for quite long enough he's such
a pirate yeah the eyeliner guy liner
gotta get some get some Kia Soul hey you
guys could be brothers don't force me to
regret our Arrangement you just
concentrate on your part I've bled for
you once already without me you'd have
nothing uneasy Alliance what is the
alliance exactly
this is how we get around in this
universe this is how doors work
I got something
chaos magic Wonder
ing what
you know like Evil Dead
of the scores of brave souls who entered
lucian's Fortress a single vampire
survived Craven but were returning with
evidence of the like and Masters denials
yeah the Branded skin cut from lucian's
very arm
that's his skin uh
is his skin why is that his skin because
it's been weathered by time it's just so
thick the thick is our skin it's leather
now you're human he's been marked by a
lichen he knows did Craven put you up to
this no I saw the wound with my own eyes
I swear freaked out and went on the
ceiling it was the whole thing she must
know right I've been having these
hallucinations having these delusions
all I know is it feels like my my skull
is splitting in half okay I show a full
grown man bit you feel like I'm skull's
on fire but I'm good Michael are you
sure this wasn't a dog I said it was a
man okay it was a man okay it was a man
dog and that woman the woman from the
subway haven't you been listening to me
she took me all right hostage all right
all right and I'm in love with her yes
okay
set him up at two Wentworth Miller you
wouldn't have done this to Dominic
Purcell
[Music]
what do you know man I feel like he
knows more than they're letting on
puzzle
V is for Victor that's good enough for
me
oh
I can only hope Victor will hear my plea
you've got the juju you're the special
[Music]
it's always the wrist of the Palm man
if this wakes him up though then why
would they ever not be awake you know it
would take a lot of blood probably
they'd have to keep it going constantly
okay organ pumping I believe that Lucian
is Alive and Well
now in this very City
during The Awakening ceremony no she
knows too much
whoa
super curious what how she's gonna go
about this
is she hiding what's oppressing
Michael
Is It Michael is he better than me do
you like him more than me if you go to
him you'll never be welcome in this
house again now that Victor's awake
we'll see what he has to say about that
Boogie
hey uh so I don't know what she told you
but her human Michael he's not a human
at all he's a lichen
come on
[Music]
oh my God whether you like it or not
you're in the middle of a war that's
been raging for the better part of a
thousand years a blood feud between
vampires and lichens
werewolves
oh most humans die within an hour of
being bitten by an immortal the viruses
will be transmitted deadly and if you
bit me what I become a vampire instead
how do you know that no one's ever
survived the bike from both species
I track down and kill your kind I am the
interest is finding out why Lucian wants
you so badly dude man bite him he's got
different blood create the combo you
must let her come to me we have much to
discuss Celine and I you must not be
named is that he has shown me a great
many
disturbing things
that will be dealt with soon enough by
your [__] ass what you will do is
summon Marcus
oh but he still Slumbers my Lord yeah
summon his ass council members are
arriving tomorrow night to awaken Marcus
not you my Lord you've been awakened a
full Century ahead of schedule oh no is
that bill nyhee yeah he kind of looks
like his voice it sounds like yeah like
that's a wild guess but I'm so with you
I feel like maybe this is one of the
places we use for interrogations
huh yeah save for the interrogator why
do you hate them so much I've already
told you so you're just following orders
good question
why do they hate each other we've gotten
nothing so far
thing was in the stable tearing our
horses to pieces I couldn't have saved
my mother or my sister my father died
outside trying to fend them off about to
run to my niece's room
oh how did she turn to a vampire though
the war had spilled into our house
for days he drove them off and saved me
he turned me Victor yeah damn that night
he made me a vampire he gave me the
strength to avenge my family
I like that yeah
ooh rocking load boys
with those special bullets yeah I get
those ultraviolet sunlight rounds I'm
not staying here alone you will if you
want to live no you're not with you
likes you
yeah yeah
let's go let's go oh please oh thank
goodness
yeah
the way she was coming onto him that
easily when the full Moon Rises tomorrow
night you will change he will kill and
you will feed it's unavoidable can't
leave you free to roam around I'm sorry
so I'm Gonna Leave You chained to this
table that you'll probably rip out of
the floor single railroad Kelly where
the silver should prevent the
transformation at least for a few hours
if I don't return in time do yourself a
favor use it use the favor and yourself
oh she's shook Baba shook as true she
just she did just get to Mac on your boy
it was cute although I feel like he just
cheated on Meredith oh can't have that
they were on a little bit of a break
though so we were on a break
embarrassed
in Paris in front of everyone he'll go
before
they tell them exactly what I tell you
to from here on out you'll do as I say
is that in any way unclear
whoa I've been lost without you my Lord
be hounded by Craven in his never-ending
oh no he desires the one thing he cannot
have you a tale as old as time but I did
see Lucian I shot him you must believe
me there's been a little complication
the coven is in danger and Michael is
the
it's definitely Bill nahi give me the
chance to get the proof
fine
ah damn it no these rules these rules
are in place for a good reason
the only reason we have survived this
long the system works you will not be
shown an ounce of leniency when Amelia
arrives the council will convene and
decide your fate damn dude that's cold
you have broken the chain and the
Covenant you must be judged
now the single tear the single tier
instead out of this now you'll be lucky
if I can convince the console to spare
your life did you have the nerve to cut
the skin from his arm or did illusion to
it for you yeah
try to look guiltier man no one opens
this door understood can afford that my
future Queen run off that lichen again
you're my future wife she's pissed she's
gonna open the door she wants her gone
because she wants to be his wife yeah
and on to you Julia Stiles no ways Moab
thank you yeah
how do I aim this thing
foreign
chew your hand off that's a suggestion
change of plans Amelia will be picked up
by Soren and his team
that's agile not anymore
you've been reassigned my guy Amelia
Bedelia
[Music]
platform nine and three quarters after
Dark
oh
yes dress oh Dad we're bringing denim in
is that what that is that can't be damn
is it I don't know it had like chiffon
over some oh no it's silk underneath
what is that trimming
oh the necklaces everything yeah I love
this costume designer
nice
yes
Matrix glasses vision
you know when people suspend themselves
through their skin that's like a thing
now yeah that's what that looks like
true that was his Kink when he was alive
why are you helping me I'm not
myself yeah I just want you out of here
girl you too good for craving team up
with Celine come on yeah I love that I'm
not I'm helping me we're looking down
the Mansion
she's escaped to go to him to Michael I
want that Legend's head on a plate
french fried potatoes
we're gonna have a showdown between
Michael and Celine as he's turning
there's probably gonna be something like
that but what about the power of love
yeah they'll think they're fighting but
then they'll realize that they have a
common enemy
together
seems like a definite asset always have
a very winding staircase yep
thank you
get down get down
what are you a little [__] are you
kidding me
jumping would have been better what
you're doing is
there you go werewolf power's kicking in
oh is it the guys from the hospital yeah
I hope she felt like a badass I mean in
this get up you gotta feel like
everything you do is freaking cool yeah
I mean it should have arrived by now yes
I want you to slip off the property and
find out what's keeping her you've got
it I thought you'd never ask Amelia
Bedelia be dead
[Music]
gotta get some of that blood give me
that funk that good that nasty stuff
thank you
oh yeah
so the cops on the werewolf team or I
don't know if it's like all cops or if
it's just like these cops yeah I'm just
saying do they know he's turning right
now because like are they idiots yeah
they know they are just idiots no I
think they don't know
oh
not bad use of CGI
that is a very digital transformation
yeah this ain't gonna go well
he's got different blood yeah
it was a great call by you your
incompetence is becoming most
things that I'm at the core of some
ridiculous conspiracy and here's my
proof
[Music]
nice now I want you to tell them exactly
what you told me for years we've been
trying to question the bloodlines
oh my God are they gonna answer the
question yeah the key we knew was to
locate the rarest of Bloodlines a direct
descendant of Alexander covinus yes
this body was able to change the disease
mold it to its benefit
the first straw immortal he's the
special it's a ridiculous Legend the
covina's train itself was hidden away
the genetic code of his human
descendants
in its dormant form the sea virus
Through the Ages
to Michael Colvin
his blood allows for a perfect feeling
between our species
you're wrong you're living in the past
man one solution has ejected illusion is
dead
according to who
according to this [__]
Craven will pay with his
life evolution
was I able to get his hands
out of the people and inject it along
with Michael's blood
yes
oh I'm so excited
this is all I've ever wanted Robert I
know you kind of said that at the
beginning dude
I was really into that scene
I feel like I just blacked out watching
out I was like hanging on his every word
he did a really good job there I need to
speak with Khan
Khan the council members have been
assassinated
it has begun it has already begun
man
wow
damn that's a punch the great effect I'm
bummed he's dead because I liked him
yeah he's a great character actor fear
not my child
absolution
with yours I don't trust him cry for
moment you kill the descendant of
corvinus this
damn it I don't trust him all these old
guards got to go I
have to deal
There's No Going Back The
Vampires will kill you on sight
for being what you are one of us one of
us one of us but I'm in love with one of
them
bringing an end to this conflict
yeah Bill Nye started it I knew it
cool like jittery ghosty effect
so is he in love with her or something
but she's a vampire must be his bae
[Music]
Sonia red Sonia
damn
I left smart to hide some of that stuff
and all the editing I was born in
servitude
yet I hovered them no ill will even took
a vampire for my bride
it was forbidden and they probably
weren't happy about that Victor
feared a blending of the species
he killed her it's an allegory for
interracial marriages
[Music]
would you like to know Timber and Victor
said I love you like my own daughter
yeah
does this mean Craven doesn't suck
that's what I said remember I predicted
that earlier dude good call feel bad now
for ribbon on him no I mean his
personality still sucks
fair this movie is low-key very good
it's a lot of fun I'd expect me to some
control now that Victor's been awakened
and that is precisely why I need Michael
if Victor was so easy to dispatch
you'd have done it yourself ah you could
have done it while he was sleeping
what whoa what just happened oh is he
gonna Hulk out
hahaha
think about leaving
oh he's got the other bullets now those
silver ones oh dude
no what all right take it back he does
suck that was devastating
silver nitrate that you weren't
expecting that dude oh oh this is a mess
that was devastating I really liked him
yeah and just what we found out he's not
the actual bad guy
what is she here to do save Michael yeah
they need him
gosh she's so freaking cool
God it must be so dank in here
whoa
whoa there's like razor wire or silver
whips release the Kraken
it doesn't look too bad no like I love
uh it's Unique it's different looking
yeah I love a practical transformation
but two out of three have been pretty
solid in this movie yeah they're not my
favorite but I think it's cool it's a
cool choice anyway
nice dude it's cool
swallow the camera right up
oh she got the metallic lipstick yeah I
was just saying that but now it's gone
whoa
is that Michael I don't think so it must
be the other guy Victor I mean uh it
must be the solution it must be this guy
the guy with a crazy deep voice oh yeah
yeah the one we just saw turn come on
Kevin Grievous werewolf
dang
I hope they shoot that that Matrix flip
behind you
interesting protagonist for this like
she's a mostly physical character while
like everybody else is arguing about you
know Bloodlines and we heard about her
family dying and stuff so she we have
empathy or sympathy for her that's true
that's true yeah we saw that little kiss
oh there will be another yeah for sure
peekaboo
over there
foreign
[Music]
my dude yeah Craven God look at all the
chum
look at all the bits and body parts
if you're him wouldn't you kind of be
happy to see a wolf though
I guess happier than a vamp
although none happier than to see Kate
Beckinsale
[Music]
oh Your Gun Works I kill you too just
for helping me
I know
oh kiss he sees it but he fell I know it
started the war
oh no but why wouldn't Lucian want him
to tell her then she'll be on their team
yeah man
she deserves to know especially because
Victor turned her like
dang man wow
that was fast
this is my finishing sword that was cool
though to see how strong he is because
we heard about it
I wonder if Michael feels akin to them
now like stop killing my kind it's got
to be growing on him at least
[Music]
ah damn it man
I'll kill him
step in front of him oh the silver no oh
that's fun too they must have had squibs
loaded with silver here come with me
I hope I live long enough to see Victor
choke the life from you I bet you do but
let me tell you a little something he's
the one who killed your family I knew it
I was thinking that I was thinking that
I should have said it but I knew it so
every once in a while I'm not engorged
himself in human blood I get the secrets
cleaned up the mess knew it that past
he got to you
he just couldn't bear the thought of
draining you dry egg you you reminded
him so much of his precious Sonia your
place is by my side
we're in love still so be it
no
whoa
my man
is it dead bite him yes come on yeah
let's see if he can withstand it bite
him
almost like
he's not looking so good come on
he's got one good eye left oh it tastes
like a quarter red
Oh shot you may have killed me
oh my will
he's done regardless
so long cuz Okay so Victor does suck
suck I mean uh Craven Victor sucks yeah
they both suck suck in different ways
[Music]
nice wire work
nice oh
he's blood though right forgive me my
child
it was like it it was you
don't tell him you know whoa
yes whoa I've been waiting for this all
my life
because he's a bastard is it not a fair
trade the life I have grown to do that
the gift of immortality now life of your
daughter I'd imagine none of us had a
choice in the matter
is he growing wings wings is he a fairy
yeah
yes he's going to be very effeminate
after this transformation is done I
loved my daughter
but the Abomination growing in Hawaii
was a betrayal of me and of the Covenant
she was pregnant
did what was necessary to protect the
species
as I am forced to do yet again
God you guys in your pure blood
dang dude
for a second I thought he was gonna have
bat wings how'd he get down there
whoa so how's he doing that he's got
like super Supernatural Speed and
Agility
as an angry like Empire
[Laughter]
that stunt looked a little wiry
Bill Knight he's thrown down these
stunts boy
so dank
Come On Celine jump in there I think she
would just get a hurt right
[Music]
no no
come on mcliken
yeah okay yeah it's gotta do what's
right oh folks
that's your own daughter might as well
be
[Applause]
what's gonna happen you know Victor's
gonna kill him and then they're gonna
you know Stave off the hybrid race
forever and uh we're all gonna go home
whoa
very graceful 9.8 get him
[Applause]
no
keep expecting his head to slide off
[Music]
whoa
well that is not what I thought happened
gnarly
soups Gnar also she was able to kill him
now tame the Beast
Michael looks like an avatar
yeah a little bit it's a crispy Avatar
come on
who is it
what are they hearing oh and they will
have all seen her fight on their behalf
their king queen of the underworld baby
yeah sock face suck face suck face suck
face not blood I'm bummed that Lucian
died
I know I loved him
is he back to normal
[Music]
yup yup yup I'm in place it around his
neck let's go let's go
Oh no you're going the wrong way honey
grab her grab her what I'm just gonna
follow you nude all this
meanwhile back at home yo what's
happening Marcus
yeah wake him up
let him out let him out yeah the
consequences of this night will
reverberate through the holes of both
great Caverns for many years of course
through all the sequels to come
Marcus will take the throne the tide of
anger and retribution will spill out
into the night
differences will be set aside oh boy and
soon
I will become the hunted no
[Music]
no who's waking Marcus Amelia's dad
well there's that guy Bleeding Out
damn so does that mean what right
what
Kevin Grievous yeah I think that's how
you say it he had a story credit as well
I think he he worked on like
Frankenstein cried he wrote this movie
that's so wild to me
I didn't realize I mean you know like it
was like a surprise when they did
Halloween
2019 or whatever that was or no that's
way too reason 2017. when they do the
Blum House Halloween and Danny McBride
co-wrote it everyone was like what I had
no idea if it is the same Danny McBride
that's a wild thing I mean is there more
than one Danny McBride
not that I know of in Hollywood but I'm
just like it's such a common sounding
name that I gotta imagine damn oh Scotty
Scott Speedman there you go that's his
name don't wear it out well and was uh
was Kate Beckinsale married to Len
Wiseman when this happened I don't know
who that is he's the director oh and
this is one of those like that's how
they met maybe what else did he Direct
you know
various
action stuff that I don't remember well
enough to name off can I tell you
something no we're not here to discuss
anything
JK what did you want to tell me I really
[__] with that movie really yeah can I
tell you something even worse
sure I preferred that to Blade
wow shots fired I really like blade I
love blade but so no shots fired at
Blaine I just thought this was awesome
this was really scary we enjoyed that I
think that there were a lot of twists
and turns I feel like Kate Beckinsale
really held it down then there was like
just when you think you've got it it
wasn't too many twos and turns but I was
like oh snap that's smart that's cool I
loved the costume design in this I love
the set design I think that it was
everything that one of these movies in
the early 2000s should be I feel like
that holds up really well
um I was super into that movie yeah yeah
I don't know if I would necessarily put
it above blade for me but for what I
think anybody would but me but I do it's
all good no I'm like I'm excited that's
awesome and yeah like this is another
one of those movies that like I remember
the moment in time when it was first
coming out I remember people talking
about it
um but yeah this has that sort of
perfectly satisfying like it's a little
bit cheesy at times but in a way that I
appreciated I've had fun with I was
never not having fun and enjoying myself
and as a fan of both these kinds of lore
and then you know combining them at you
know in that Matrix era where it is like
let's get leather and sunglasses and
latex and Industrial music together and
all that stuff like yeah this was a very
satisfying concoction and this felt like
I don't know if this is actually
inspired by a comic book or something
like that but it definitely felt like it
and and Kevin Grievous the the deep
voice Guy having a story by credit I
wonder if maybe it's even based off of
some kind of graphic novel he was right
oh but uh but yeah it was based off his
life
that's what I was thinking I feel like
this gave us both exactly what we wanted
though early on you jumped on I I've
always wanted to see what happened the
vampire and the Werewolf together could
it work and I was like lover of Love
shippers
and it gave us both what we were we're
looking for like yeah I think that's
what honestly a lot of movies as you
know are missing for me I need a I need
a love story sure and this had that and
not just with them but with the Sonia
and uh Lucian one I feel like that was a
really cool element that they brought in
and and like you said obviously it's an
allegory for things but I do love
Forbidden Love and why and then like
that carrying down generations and I
also love you know when you look at your
parents one way and you think they're
who you think they are and then things
shift and then all of a sudden the way
she was looking at Victor her whole
world changed and I I just thought that
was bad yeah well it's got that quality
where like it is very much of the time
it came out but also like what the story
is is this sort of Timeless thing yeah
where it is about you know legacies and
deceits spread out over generations and
stuff like that and and yeah these like
feuds that rage on throughout history
and people who you know are involved
with them but who don't really know
where they came from like yeah it's it's
got that quality where you're like oh
this you could easily apply this to like
interracial romance or something like
that as like an allegorical thing
um you know so it's like kind of neat
that a movie like this would have some
kind of different classes or you know
yeah yeah just the mixing of different
stations or classes or or whatever it
might be and so it's just like a nugget
of like true life applicability that I
wasn't expecting here and also when you
come up thinking that you're on the
right side of something and then you're
not right like you you only know what
you know and until you know more yeah
and I thought it was interesting the way
that they orchestrated this because you
know it's like Celine is is ostensibly
your main character and certainly like
we we learn obviously what her backstory
is but like it's an interestingly told
movie because you learn so much about
like the lore and the situation and the
conflicts between these other characters
and I feel like she at the heart of it
is kind of an interesting like audience
Cipher almost because you're not like
really intimately getting to know her
like you're not really close to her very
much you kept you said that a couple
times but I didn't feel that way because
we knew the story of her parents we knew
we knew that uh Victor was like
surrogate dad and we knew Craven wanted
to be with her and and she was fighting
against that like I thought I felt like
we had a good grip on what her
relationships were what her goals were
what kind of human person or vampire she
was what her values were who she wanted
to help and um yeah I thought that like
I it's not like we had a lot of sit
Downs with her over coffee where it was
like what are your aspirations in this
world but I did feel like they did give
us enough for me to give a [__] about
her yeah and I think too it's cool that
she does very convincingly because of
all these different things we're talking
about she manages to feel naturally like
a figure alone at the center and between
all these things but not truly
especially when she discovers you know
like the true nature of of what the
vampires have done over time like yeah
she she does feel like this figure who's
dislodged from both Clans you know and
is able to be this kind of an island
yeah and and that seems like a fun
Prospect for sequels to come and whatnot
and even though you don't have like a
fully fledged romance here between her
and Michael like I liked the hinting
they did with that and uh or you know at
least just like the breach of
possibility yeah um and it gets twice
they did it because two times I wanted
them to kiss one more time at the end I
know well and that's that's the thing
too is I'm excited you know if we ever
get to see more of these like um which
will happen if you like the videos
friends video recommended to them but uh
but yeah like it seems it's just like a
really fun uh take and I'm sure we've
seen a bunch of things now that have uh
you know capitalized on a movie like
this and sort of taken the ball and run
with it
um but yeah it's like I I'm excited to
see what this lore can grow into because
that's as a horror that's always been a
thing of I liked it on Amazon here it
says the genres are suspense fantasy
atmospheric and biting there's a lot of
biting
but yeah it's like I I love the idea
that we're finally seeing that you know
what happens when you combine the two
you know infections the two Supernatural
diseases the two Bloodlines together
um and you know what the two of them
could become as this sort of third group
that exists in between them almost if
they're able to find people who you know
are sympathetic or whatever and I like
that too I like the the disposition of
like they really kind of give you this
convincing portrayal where you think
okay the vampires are the good-ish guys
I guess and when Bill Nye First shows up
you're like okay like you know I'm this
does seem like somebody who can help who
who can provide us a little bit of Hope
for Celine and whatnot and then and then
when the Betrayal comes down and you
find out the truth you're like damn I do
kind of feel for her position yeah now
and so it's cool to kind of watch a
movie that can sell you this main
character on One mission that you're
sort of on board for and then it you
know pulls the rug and goes oh wait the
thing we've been doing is kind of the
wrong Mission all along and it's built
off of deceits and whatnot lies yeah uh
also you pointed out what it said here
about suspense fantasy atmospheric and
biting it also says a beautiful vampire
caught up in age old battle falls in
love with one of her enemies what I like
about this is that it actually wasn't
really that she didn't fall in love with
one of her enemies like she didn't fall
in love with a wolf yeah she went to
protect a human because she was curious
what was happening I think that was a
stronger Choice than her just falling in
love with a Vampire I mean her falling
in love with a wolf because we've seen
things like that throughout the ages
yeah I thought that this was different
because they both sides wanted something
from him there was stuff going on on
both sides and I I really did enjoy that
what did you feel about the run time
that little over two hour run time
usually these movies are slightly
shorter than that I find was it did it
drag for you at all
um no not not hugely I mean there were
times there are moments where I feel
like they're I maybe expected like a bit
more stylization with certain things
like if you're comparing pound for pound
I feel like blade has slightly more like
in terms of camera like slightly more
stylish action maybe
um I agree with that fluid in that
department but uh
I don't know I mean this is this is kind
of the vibe I was certainly expecting
the tone and yeah it's it's uh it's a
fun fantasy world that has yeah like the
right kind of cheese so it wasn't really
dragging there are moments where it does
feel a little predictable or whatever or
or you know like the vampires in certain
cases are so true to character as this
movie draws them that you can see
certain things coming or they'll behave
you know with such Hubris in certain
moments that you're like ah right I can
see what's about to happen but in a way
that never like
uh never took away from the experience
for me yeah I'm with you on that uh Kate
Beckinsale to me when you think of her
like this is what she's known for the
most right I guess so isn't that kind of
weird like put her on the map not to uh
call you out or put you on the spot but
like what are other Kate Beckinsale
famous roles I know she's in The Aviator
she plays Ava Gardner
like I know she's on social media
playing with her cats is that what she
does right I see that all the time like
this is this was this what put her on
the map initially I feel like it was
yeah yeah and housing
oh yeah I remember Van Helsing too but
yeah I mean like this is her this is her
franchise I know and I wonder if they'll
revive it again at some point I mean
there was one in 2016. so it seems like
one of the more reliable aspects of her
career yeah wow there was one in 2016
how many have there been
four or five
Pearl Harbor that certainly would have
also done yeah yeah it was Pearl Harbor
before this yeah two years okay also
it's a different Danny McBride from what
I gather it's not the same day okay so
what else has he done a lot of
Underworld he's like the shepherd I mean
you and I were both he's done a whole
bunch of Underworld and he did Fallen
Angel oh no Fallen Angel was short
different following yeah
huh yeah interesting okay I'm glad that
you clarified that because I'm sure in
the comments people were gonna be like
different it's not that Danny McBride
that would have been wild yeah can you
tell me what the director has done Lynn
Wiseman yeah I know he's done you said
they they were married
I think so it's still weird
I think they got divorced eventually
give me that tea give me that gossip
lover of Love shippers ships oh Total
Recall I know he's a producer on that
yeah oh he was the EP on Swamp Thing
remake that's wild yeah okay all right
let's see director what you got
something TV series Sleepy Hollow TV
series Total Recall remake
yeah I mean underworld is certainly his
like big claim to fame and uh and yeah I
mean I could I could see how this would
have launched him I mean like you know
this didn't have like the most
directorial voice where I'm like damn
gotta see more of what this specific
director does
um but I liked a lot of the production
designs and I liked a lot of you know
the the tone and the pace and stuff like
that it has an appropriately dreary kind
of again Matrix you know hodgepodge Vibe
where it's yeah rain and leather and
coats I thought he had a good sense of
his characters as a director though like
I agree with you that it was I felt like
this was as stylized as blade in terms
of set design and costumes but not in
terms of cinematography
um necessarily but I do feel like he I
don't know he seemed like an actor's
director I obviously wasn't on set but I
thought there was some really solid
performances I knew where I stood with
everybody yeah I really dug this I
really dug this I'm glad man I hope that
we watch more of these likewise like
this yeah likewise like this yeah this
is to me had sort of almost like a
midnight movie quality but in a in a
good way like I felt like I was watching
a b movie but in a way that I you know
was was always like a fun kind of a b
move I kind of expect it to feel that
way going into this so maybe that's why
I was surprised like I I don't know I
feel like this is a really good movie
sure I know I really enjoyed it I guess
I I probably from the outside expected
something that was a bit more slick like
this wasn't quite as slick as I expected
it had all like the designs and all the
production values of something I
expected but it wasn't quite as like ooh
kinetic crazy again like a lot of the
look and the and then and like the
visual Flair wasn't exactly what I
expected and and it's in a way where it
wasn't overly overdone you know it was
less kind of stylized then in a way
that's less distracting you could argue
so yeah we have to watch more so that we
can see what happened to Julia Stiles
yeah oh and she did a good job too I
mean like yeah I liked there were
certain I like the Craven character I
was like this like you know he was
always uh him again this dude yeah yeah
yeah just the kind of character where
I'm like man even when I think you're
kind of on our side I don't really like
you that much and and not in like uh oh
it's taking away from the movie but just
yeah like just like ah totally just
seemed like that kind of character who's
like even when you're on the right side
you're just like you're on my nerves but
I understood his motivation yeah yeah it
was cool yeah and I like the murkiness
of that of like okay so maybe he's
helping Lucian out okay well sort of but
not really he's all self-serving in the
end you're all looking out for
themselves yeah yeah totally so like I
liked I think my favorite aspects are
just like the way the conflict is drawn
and the way that that affects the
characters I think that was the most
interesting element and and like Michael
Sheen man killing it Bill Nighy great as
well uh why are you helping me am I
helping you I'm helping me yeah I'm
helping me that's right I'm gonna start
are you telling me the people that you
liked I just love the line yeah Michael
Sheen anybody else that really stood out
for you uh I mean I liked your boy I
thought he did a fine Jaime mostly he
just kind of has to be in agony and and
you know buff Wentworth Miller not in
too much of it no no yeah this is
probably on the come up for him but it
was nice yeah nice to see him you know
and uh and yeah it's uh I I'm excited
hopefully to see more of Celine I feel
like there's a a lot of potential for
her to grow in this role and to you know
continue making it her own because she's
got so many she's like when she steps on
screen she's just so badass it kind of
reminded me of like me you
uh Jessica Beale and like Blade Trinity
but but this is better than that yeah
um I mean Jessica Biel is great in that
movie wasted you know in that movie as
so many of the good parts of that movie
were but uh but yeah this gave me kind
of kind of that Vibe yeah I feel you I I
definitely feel you on that any final
thoughts on underworld no is a good time
man I'm glad we saw it I'm glad you
enjoyed it as much I I didn't quite
enjoy it as much as you but this was
still a lot of fun and yeah for me again
as a fan of werewolves vampires uh
cyberpunk uh and the question of what
happens when you combine the two
um I mean and that's that's maybe one
thing is uh as like I can easily forgive
like yeah you know it's it's it's the
2000s We're not gonna do like a Rick
Baker practical werewolf transformation
yeah and I liked the Abomination the the
hybrid design but part of me was like oh
man I wish this was a little more like
he kind of looked mostly like a super
werewolf or it's like I wanted slightly
more bat-like features maybe from that
you wanted wings and you didn't get
wings get my wings my big old pointy
ears well when we're done with this you
can go get some wings yeah Buffalo
Barbecue lemon pepper whatever you want
what does that mean I've been working
for 10 hours and all I want is wig stop
I don't know but I definitely like it
there you're gonna so you liking their
liking there who do we like in the most
today who do we like we like Danny
pancakes all right because Danny knows
why I wrote this but it's not the Danny
McBride it sounds like a little
disappointing but you know it's not
disappointing you hear Danny pancakes
and you're like breakfast is served I
just want to slather you in some syrup
my dude I just wanna a little whipped
cream yeah some chocolate chips yeah ooh
banana let me ask you this uh and you
have to answer honestly even though it's
Danny pancakes waffles or pancakes oh
dude it depends on the day okay mine's
always pancakes and that's why Danny's
my guy pancakes it's always pancakes
waffles are good but they're not Danny
pancakes they're not Danny pancakes no
you don't want to you don't want to
start your day off with anything other
than Danny pancakes all right no it's my
first time in the morning last stop
before I go to sleep is waking up next
morning to some more Danny pancakes
Danny puts that D on the paint like the
D on the p
[Music]
and that's how we know we love Danny
pancakes thanks for being a super sexy
thanks for being sexy Danny P baby you
must wear a lot of leather oh definitely
yeah he's watching this in a full latex
jumpsuit right now four set coat you
know sunglasses chokers knee-highs
earrings boots all of it oh I like their
their cool like silver nitrate and like
UV bullets too that was cool that was
cool we should get different types of
bullets and Technology whatever they
were creating I was like oh
yeah it was good Danny's got the syrup
bullets though oh I would
I would take a certain bullet
I would I would take a short roll if you
went to like a breakfast bar and they
were like Circle I believe load it up
yeah fire away they're gonna go to
Benihana and they put the oil in the
squeeze can syrup me anyway let's get
out of here yes or I say something weird
thanks for joining us for underworld
well we appreciate that what's this it's
a heart that I'm also looking through Oh
I thought you were doing some
nighttime vision uh thank you for going
Danny's pancakes wait I'm about to make
a good pun thank you for going over
underworld with us
because over the opposite under
like the video so that we can watch more
of this I really like this one and would
love to see some more with you guys do
it let's go on a journey okay later